let's sing back a little bit if you have
a function like this like a straight
line right we know if you have it in a
floor like this it's really easy to find
its gradient in fact it's you don't even
really have to find anything if I gave
the equation of the line to you which
there's some time on linear functions in
that form you would say the gradient is
just M right the gradient is just M we
have twisted around the equation of that
line such that the gradient is just
sitting there and that's why we call it
gradient intercept form however if you
rewind a little bit and go back to if
you didn't know that there was this way
to write the equation of a line you
could still find the gradient of it you
just need two points on there what would
you do with those two points what would
you do you did watch into your gradient
formula weren't you now help me out here
right what is the gradient formula in
terms of the shape of what you're
looking at right well you need two
points and then you sort of draw this
right angle triangle right what do you
do with this right angle triangle ah
really really Pythagoras to find to find
the gradient all you need is to compare
the rise yeah it's early I did it the
ride over here with the run over here
it's somewhat arbitrary that we decide
to make it rise every one you could have
made it run over ride but we tend to
make Y the dependent variable and X the
independent one so this says how do you
change upwards as you change
horizontally and of course we have
values for each of these if your first
point x1 y1 your second point x2 y2
what's our what is the value of the
rights what's the top of your gradient
formula what's on a new rail it's going
to be the difference between this
y-coordinates right which is y2 minus y1
and the same thing for run except X is
right okay so
rise over run is really just a nice
memorable way of saying how does the why
change in comparison to how the X
changes so in fact I'm going to write it
like that change in Y change in X okay
so far so good
now I don't even care about gradient
well in the first place like all the way
back when you first learn the grain in
formula we kind of only care about it
because we can work it out it's like
what maybe I can actually find this area
it's not too complicated I can subtract
numbers I can divide numbers and out
pops a gradient but it's not really
clear why this number is important so
let me try and explain a little bit at
the moment I've laid my label my axes or
I've sort of implied that my axes are an
X and a y-axis right and X and Y axis
but these axes can refer to anything for
example if I said this our horizontal
axis with something like say time and
this vertical axis or something like say
position then the change in Y compared
to the change in X would be the same as
the change in position compared to the
change in time right so this is like a
rate a change in position or
displacement is another physics where
you might have heard before this is the
change in time now we have units that
compare these right like a position is
like a length of measurement right so
you might say that's something like
kilometers that's a measure of position
a measure of length a measure a time
that's fairly commonly used is something
like say the hour right so you've got a
position you've got a time we wouldn't
usually write it like this would usually
write it like that which helps you see
when you're measuring something in
kilometers per hour what are you
measuring you are measuring speed or
velocity if you want to be a bit fancier
about it right so in other words if you
compare these two things and how they
change you get a rate which is important
like which is useful which applies to a
real situation of
right like speed okay so this comparison
here if you compare change what you get
is a rent and rates are really important
because lots and lots of things change
so far so good we know why gradient sort
of matters except we really rapidly hit
a roadblock like we've spent a lot of
time on linear functions early this year
but it doesn't take very long to get two
functions that are no longer straight
lines and which resists this simple way
of doing things right on that first
diagram you know how I pick those two
points you could pick them anywhere cut
you right and you would still get
exactly the same result but this guy is
different if you pick two points like
say he are dude here I could find out
the gradient between these two points
couldn't no I could do the same rise
over run see that I did before but of
course if I pick a different pair of
points excuse me I think a different
pair of points like say this one and
this one you get a whole different
gradient don't you for example in this
case your rise is going to be negative
right and your run is going to be a
completely unrelated number so the
reason why we have this problem here is
that well the gradient keeps changing
there isn't just one gradient all the
way along for this straight line that's
why there is no gradient intercept form
for a parabola because the green is
different wherever you have a look ok so
therefore we're trying to interested in
this idea of ok what is the gradient
each individual point it can keep
changing right so we no longer call a
gradient borrowing on some language from
our previous topic we call it a gradient
function because it can change right so
let me just write that down here the
gradient function
figure out all the stuff you know about
functions already in fact if you still
have the pages there turn back to where
we define a function a function is as
you might remember I'll give you a bit
of a nudge a function is a special kind
of equation what's special about it
because not every equation is a function
what's special ah yeah okay so you're
there there are two variables right you
put a number in and you get a number out
does that make sense
and you only every time you put $1 in
you only get one number as opposed to
say our relation right so the gradient
function is exactly the same the
gradient function is what takes in like
this is the input it takes in an x value
and what it provides is a gradient and
outputs agreement
okay now I've titled this the problem of
tangents because we don't want to have
between these two points because if you
have a look it's not hard to draw and
you can draw this on to your own as well
if I join up these guys here you don't
actually get the gradient at any
particular point because it sort of
slices across this is not a tangent this
is a secant right by the way
secant secant it's called a secret
because it cuts the shape it cuts the
line in a couple of different spots what
we want is a tangent tangent which as
opposed to cutting like a secant right
like a cross-section is something that
cuts across we want something that is
tangential now what does that mean what
is a tangent we've heard of this word
before to do with circles anyone want to
give a one-sentence as brief as you can
definition of what a tangent is yes
okay let me repeat that and let me get
your ideas on what we think you the
suggestion so far is a straight line a
straight line that touches the the curve
the shape the function only once there's
two things with another straight line
touches only once what do you think that
seems like a reasonable definition
you've learnt about tangents in
respective circles so far there's a
straight line
it touches only once looks pretty
tangent T to be right if it were a
secret it would touch twice do you agree
straight line touches only once doesn't
it
is it a tangent so how are you going to
fix the definition it's not a bad
definition it's a good way to start
someone else want to suggest how we
could tweak this what could we add is
there something we can add that's going
to make this not a tangent and that
attention what's the difference between
them someone else is there anyone else
or work enough to have a think about we
said straight lines and we said touches
only once any takers
any takers someone else someone ever
think come on you can all see what it is
what words would you use to describe
what's going on hmm okay this is tricky
right I'm going to give you an informal
definition and then you'll see why we're
doing this and why we've had to do
limits wire has all these pieces to make
sense of it here's my informal
definition it just touches only one
right now I get that from the word
hedges tangent there's lots of words of
the English language that have common
ancestry right there's a word in the
English language that starts just the
same way and this is what it's talking
about
right any takers the word tangible right
tangible it means you can touch
something as a person is in danger which
you can you can't touch okay that's what
this is really talking about it just
touches and then it leaves off okay